welcome back to age 20. in this section
we want to talk about time time keeping
and how to relate time between two
different reference files
now let me start with a quote by albert
einstein
everything should be as simple as
possible
but not simpler
so let's start with this in mind
and recall that
we ended the last section by finding
that you know the wave ether model
doesn't really describe electromagnetic
waves uh very well we see that there's a
problem between the experiments
specifically the one by michaelson molly
and the theoretical picture people had
in mind
so einstein approached this
in a
interesting way he simply postulated the
things he thought need to be true
he said the same law of electrodynamics
will be valid for all reference frames
where all laws of mechanics hold good
this is the principle of relativity
the second postulate
is that light is always propagated in
empty space at a velocity c independent
of the state of motion
of the emitting body
so with this two postulates we will now
derive the theory of special relativity
and again we'll start by talking about
time
so time
is suspect and i alluded to this already
when we looked at galilean
transformation very simply out of our
intuition assumed that time is invariant
now
when we now
talk about time the the viewpoint i
would like you to have is that we want
to look at clocks from different
reference frames we want to investigate
whether or not events happen
simultaneously or not
what does that mean
when we make a statement like a train
arrives at seven o'clock what we mean is
that there is a
simultaneous two simultaneous event
happen one is that this little
clock here shows
uh to point at seven and twelve meaning
that it indicates to us that this event
indicates to us that it's seven o'clock
and the second event is that the train
actually arrives at the station
so those two events happen
simultaneously
the question now is whether or not
two observers
one stationary and one moving
agree with this observation
and i'll take it away the answer is no
there is a relativity of simultaneity
meaning that two observers can very much
agree on the description of two events
but not necessarily that those two
events happen simultaneously
so let's investigate and we use our two
friends alice and bob in order to have
this discussion
all right so we start from a situation
where alice and bob are both stationary
alice is on her spacecraft and she has a
device on a spacecraft which shoots
light or paint balls
towards two clocks and each time this
happens the clock ticks
right and we just look at one situation
so she has a clock on the left and the
clock on the right
bob observes alice's clock and he can
compare alice's this observation of
alice's clock with
his own
so in this stationary situation there's
a ta
and a tb those are the times of alice
and bob
both are zero this is when the situation
starts
and the capital t indicates
for
ls and for bob
when
they observe that the clock has been hit
i should add here that when we talk
about observation in this entire class
unless i make a very explicit exception
to this we don't consider the fact that
observing actually means that light has
to be emitted from the clock and enters
bob's eye in order to for him to
conclude that there was something
happening
the observation is
like taking a
an instantaneous picture
okay so we have to keep this in mind but
in this simple situation nothing is
moving
um you can hopefully agree that
the um
the times being read
for alice and bob on the left and the
right clock are all the same
now we go in the second situation where
we
use the same device but with a paintball
so now alice moves and bob is observing
her
she moves with the relative velocity v
and shoots off the paintballs with the
velocity u
the velocities will add
meaning that you know
and those two clocks are initially
synchronized so there isn't a small t a
equal small t v equals zero
once the clock hit you can hopefully
agree that uh alice and bob will agree
that
the times when the left clock and the
right clock hit are the same
right
but now we want to enter the situation
where we use light so we use a phaser in
order to do the very same so einstein
just postulated that the speed of light
is constant is c
and it's the same in all reference
frames and it's independent of the
emitter which means that we cannot add
at the velocities anymore so the
velocity
um
as seen by alice of light is c the
velocity of light
of the same light by the moving observer
bob is also c
so here we can
conclude that the times
for alice for where the situation is
stationary both clocks will hit at the
very same time
those two events clock 1 and clock 2 hit
i hit r simultaneous
while for bob this is clearly not the
case
you can see here
you can see here that this this
lagging
clock is being hit first while the
leading clock is hit a little a little
while after
so
if bob and alice now meet and discuss
whether or not those two events happen
simultaneously they will disagree for
alice those two clocks were hit
simultaneously this at the same time for
her by for bob
um the
first clock was hit first and the second
the leading clock was hit second
all right we can conclude
that two events can be simultaneously to
one observer
but not to another one
this
is rather confusing and we will see and
use this fact a few times later on when
we discuss
the famous paradoxes of special
relativity
so let's look at this
in a concept question to just make sure
that we're all on the same page again we
discuss here diagram three alice moves
to the right bob is the observer satisfy
the fire surfacer at
times equals zero
um
then the situation unfolds at time t a
capital t a alice observes that both
clocks are hit at time t b1 bob observes
that the left clock is hit at time tb2
it's the right clock
which of the following answers is
correctly
so here you want to stop the video and
think about which of the answers is
correct
so moving forward
the correct answer is
number three
where tb1 is smaller than ta is smaller
than tb2
so again the leading clock
lags the leading clock has a larger tb
which means for that clock
ticks a little slower
and again the two events that can be
simultaneously to one observer alice in
this case but not to another bob
all right let's look at clocks a little
bit more and design an optical clock
so here the situation is as follows we
have two mirrors in which we inject
light the light travels up and travels
down and that's what we call one clock
tick of this optical clock
the length between the two mirrors is l
so for alice she has this clock in her
hand and she can happily observe you
know the ticking
of the clock
okay bob observes alice clock and
compares it with his own identical clock
there's a relative speed between alice
and bob and that that's v in x direction
now the task for you is to relate the
clock ticks
which are observed by bob and the ones
which are observed by alice in alice's
clock
so again stop the video and work out the
algebra
the answer is going to be again
surprising
so if we do this now
we
find this picture so we calculate how
long does the clock tick take the light
has to travel to l with the velocity c
so the clock tick is 2 l over c the
length can be expressed as c times t
delta t a over 2. for bob the situation
is a little bit more complicated and we
have to use photographs in order to
calculate calculate the length so we
define that the length the light has to
travel as d then the delta t b as bob
observes this is two times d
over c again for bob the light travels
with the speed of light and einstein
just postulated test and then we find
the length x expressed to the time as c
times delta t b over two
the length in x is simply given by the
relative velocity v times the time it
takes for the clock to tick v times
delta tb so then we can express d square
d square we are l square plus x square
over 4
and use those expressions here so we
just use this for l
this for d
and this for x and we find this
expression here
all right and then we solve this for
delta t b
and we find the relation between delta t
b and delta t a and can
find that it's one over square root one
minus v square over c square which is
the lower factor
so we just this is simple clock and
einstein's postulate derived
time dilation
we find that
for
bob alice's moving clock moves slower
great so again gamma is 1 over
square root 1 minus v square over c
square we often use
in short beta as a relativistic velocity
it's unitless and defined as v over c
um gamma is always greater or equal one
and it's mostly one for everything we
observe in nature
so
in one of the psets
and also here i invite you to simply
calculate values for gamma for things
you might think are fast moving objects
so we start with a fighter jet
we look at the international space
station the earth around the sun a
particle which almost moves with the
speed of light and the proton at the
large hadron collider which is only
three meters per second slower than the
speed of light
so again stop the video and work out
regardless numbers you will need a
calculator for that
so if i do this i find
for this very very fast f-15 fighter jet
which moves with
2 680 kilometers per hour that the
number for gamma is one
point zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero which is eleven
zeros three
so we find this very very uh small
number or number which is very very
close to one
situation for the international space
station changes a bit only nine zeros
for the earth around the sun the earth
is really really fast travels a long
distance every year you travel once
around the sun and
you know every year you get older you
have a lot of mileage on your back
here you have eight zeros
particle which moves with 0.9 times the
speed of light here the gamma factor is
very different from one it's 2.3 and the
protons we have at the lhc they have a
gamma factor of 7000. so you see once
you get close to the speed of light the
gamma factor
approaches large numbers
and that's where our relativistic
effects really are visible
you